AND GOOD AFTERNOON WE WANT TO
BEGIN THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE AT
SUCH SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE'VE
NOTICED THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
ELICIT ANY OBJECTIONS.
I WANT TO FIRST BE BEGIN BY
GIVING ON THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE A
DOVE A WARM WELCOME NOT ONLY TO
THE LEGISLATURE UP TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU KNOW WE WILL BE A BIG
STRONG OF VOICE.
AND WE APPRECIATE THAT.
MISTER TOUGH YOU OKAY WITH THAT
WOULD LIKE TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND AFTER THAT THE STATE THAT MR
OBERNOLTE WILL BE ABSENT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AB NINETEEN NINETY NINE WOULD
EXPAND THE AUTHORITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
TO DEVELOP PUBLIC BROADBAND
SERVICES WHILE PRESERVING NET
NEUTRALITY TO ENSURE THE
INTERNET REMAINS OPEN. AND
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
BROADBAND ACCESS IS OF VITAL
IMPORTANCE THE ECONOMIC THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE IN
IMPORTANT PARTNER IN ENSURING
THAT ITS BENEFITS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZES MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICTS AND PUBLIC UTILITY
DISTRICTS TO OPERATE THEIR OWN
BROADBAND NETWORKS. BUT OTHER
FORMS OF INDEPENDENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE LIMITED
AUTHORITIES TO DO SO FOR EXAMPLE
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS CAN
INITIALLY PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
BUT HAVE TO SEE OVER THE
AUTHORITY ONCE A PRIVATE ENTITY
IS WILLING TO DEPLOY THE SERVICE.
RESTRICTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM BUILDING OUT THEIR OWN HIGH
SPEED NETWORKS IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO CLOSING
CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL DIVIDE.
ESPECIALLY IN ROAD AREAS WERE
ONLY FORTY THREE PERCENT.
THE POPULATION HAS ACCESS TO
BROADBAND IN THEIR HOUSE VOTES
OR IN AREAS THAT HAVE ONLY
ACCESS TO ONE PROVIDER. OR WHERE
THERE IS A LACK OF ONGOING
INVESTMENT.
NOW THE IDEA THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OUGHT TO PLAY A MORE
ACTIVE ROLE IN VOTING OUT
LOCALLY OWNED BROADBAND NETWORKS
HAS ALSO BEEN REKINDLED. BY THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS OUR
RECENT ACTION THE FCC TO REPEAL
NET NEUTRALITY RUSE.
A FORMER NET NEUTRALITY RUSE
ESSENTIALLY REQUIRE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO OFFER EQUAL
ACCESS TO ALL WEB CONTENT
WITHOUT CHARGING CONSUMERS FOR
HIGHER QUALITY DELIVERY OR
GIVING PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT.
OUGHT TO CERTAIN WEBSITES.
NOW THE REPEAL WAS DONE DESPITE
STRONG OPPOSITION FROM THE
PUBLIC.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT POLL
CONDUCTED BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
MARYLAND.
ON IN JUST TO DAYS PRIOR TO THE
REPEAL MORE THAN EIGHTY PERCENT
OF THE VOTERS OPPOSE THE F. C.
C.'S PLAN TO REPEAL IT'S OUR NET
NEUTRALITY RUSE.
S. LOCALLY OWNED BROADBAND
NETWORKS ARE BECOMING
ALTERNATIVE FOR CONSUMERS IT
SHOULD BE THE STATE'S POLICY TO
UPHOLD THE TENETS OF AN OPEN
INTERNET BY REQUIRING ADHERENCE
TO THE CORE PRINCIPLES OF NET
NEUTRALITY.
THIS BILL AB NINETEEN NINETY
NINE WOULD AFFIRM CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AND ALSO COMPETITION
SINCE THE REPEAL OF THAT NET
NEUTRALITY RULES. WHILE
AUTHORIZING THE EXPANSION OF
PUBLIC BROADBAND SERVICES A WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE TWO WITNESSES SO.
MISTER CHRIS OUT MITCHELL WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
BROADBAND NETWORKS WITH THE
INSTITUTE FOR LOCAL SELF
RELIANCE. AS WELL AS OTHER
NATIONAL FALCON FOR CON OF WHO
IS THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AT
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION GERMAN.
TYPICALLY WE GET FIVE MINUTES ON
EACH SIDE.
.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION SO FEEL
FREE DON'T FEEL PRESSURED TO USE
THE FIVE MINUTES.
GOT OUT LAST FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I'M CHRIS MITCHELL AT THE
INSTITUTE FOR LOCAL SELF
RELIANCE WHERE FOR TWELVE YEARS
WE'VE BEEN THE GO TO EXPERTS ON
BROADBAND POLICIES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SPECIFICALLY
MUNICIPAL NETWORKS.
AND MORE RECENTLY COOPERATIVE
NETWORKS.
WE TRACK MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE.
OPERATING THEIR OWN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE.
HAVE BECOME EXPERTS AND AND
BOTH WHAT'S MADE THEM SUCCESSFUL.
AND IN THE FEW CASES IN WHICH
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
WHY THERE WERE PROBLEMS AND WHAT
TO DO TO CORRECT THOSE.
I ALSO AM THE DEPUTY HER I'M I'M
ACTUALLY THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
NEXT AND THREE CITIES AN
ORGANIZATION THAT I HELPED TO
FOUND. THAT INCLUDES LOS ANGELES
SAN JOSE SANTA MONICA SEVERAL
OTHER CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES BUT
HUNDRED EIGHTY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
BOTH OF US ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL.
WERE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF OF
LOCAL RIGHTS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THESE INVESTMENTS AND STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE.
OF THE ECOSYSTEM MAKE SURE THE
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE INTERNET
ACCESS THAT THEY NEED TO THRIVE.
I WANTED TO INCLUDE JUST A BRIEF
NOTE THAT THE.
WAYS THAT SIDDIG THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AREN'T ANY PUBLIC
UNIT GO ABOUT THIS VERY.
THERE ARE METHODS THAT ARE
EXTREMELY LOW RISK IN WHICH
CITIES TAKE ON VERY LITTLE DEBT.
AND ENGAGE AND MODELS THAT CAN
PRODUCE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GAINS AS WELL AS
OTHER GAINES FOR.
LOW INCOME HOUSING AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
THERE ARE ALSO ADDITIONAL MODELS
IN WHICH CITIES PROVIDE SERVICES
DIRECTLY.
AS THOUGH THEY THEMSELVES WERE
CABLE OR TELEPHONE ENTITIES.
AND THERE ARE INSTANCES IN WHICH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PROVIDE OPEN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ENABLE OTHER
ISPS TO USE IT TO COMPETE.
SO THERE ARE A VARIETY OF MODELS
TO CHOOSE FROM AND WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHOOSE FROM
THEM FREELY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
WANT TO ENTER A FIRST SECOND.
.
AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
A MAN SUCH A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SANTIAGO HERE.
OBERNOLTE.
BONTA.
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS THEIR.
PATTERSON.
QUICKSILVER.
RODRIGUEZ.
WE HAVE CORN YOU MEET YOU MAY
CONTINUE WITH THAT WHEN THIS
ISN'T SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SHARE AYE. CHAIRS ON
THE OTHER SANTIAGO MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE I MONIES ARE ASKED
ABOUT GOING ON THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL FOR THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION. I'LL KEEP
MY REMARKS BRIEF ON ANY TREES A
TIME BUT. REALLY WHAT IT BOILS
DOWN TO IS IS TODAY HALF OF ALL
AMERICANS HAVE ONE CHOICE WHEN
IT COMES TO HIGH SPEED BROADBAND.
AND YET FIFTY FIVE COMMUNITIES
IN AMERICAN CHOI A AYE GIGABIT
NETWORKS.
PROVIDED BY THEIR OF THE
GOVERNMENT I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
VISITING THE WORLD'S FASTEST
INTERNET COMPANY IN CHATTANOOGA
TENNESSEE WHICH IS RUN BY THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I IT IS HAVE THE FASTENING
HISTORY BEHIND HOW THE COMMUNITY
OF CHATTANOOGA WAS WAS NEGLECTED
BY THE INCUMBENTS AND HOW THE
CITY DECIDED TAKE UPON
THEMSELVES TO PROVIDE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. OB BROADBAND
ACCESS.
ONE OF THE MOST INTERESTING
THINGS THAT THAT I LEARNED FROM
MY VISIT THERE WAS THE THE ONE
OF THE LEADERSHIP TEAM ON UP
WITH EPB THE COMPANY OF THAT
REPRESENTS THE CITY.
THE FORMER EIGHTEEN T. EXECUTIVE
NOTED THE REASON WHY THAT CITY
WAS NEVER GOING TO SEEN YOU KNOW
INVESTMENTS IN NEXT GENERATION
OF BROADBAND WAS THERE WERE
CONSIDERED BY EIGHTEEN T. A TIER
THREE CITY. WHAT WHAT IS A TIER
THREE CITY IT TIER THREE CITY IS
A CITY THAT IS JUST NOT HIGH UP
IN THE PRIORITY LIST FOR THE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO TO INVEST IN
THE FUTURE?
THIS THE CITY WILL OF A
POPULATION OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH. A MEDIAN
INCOME OF FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
DOZENS OF TOWNSHIPS AND CITIES
IN CALIFORNIA QUALIFY PROBABLY
IN THIS TIER THREE STATUS.
AND WITH THE ABSENCE OF GOOGLE
FIBER AND VERIZON WHICH OF BOTH.
DICK NEW HAVE TERMINATE THEIR
EXPANSION THE FIBER. YOU WERE
LEFT WITH REGIONAL PLAYERS OUT
LIKE SONIC NORTH CALIFORNIA AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENGAGING IN AND
PUBLIC A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD FULL IF I
FULLY SUPPORT HIS BILL WE
BELIEVE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO.
YOU CAN'T TAKE THE INTERNET
INTO THEIR OWN HANDS IF THEY SO
DESIRE AND IN THIS BILL WOULD
FURTHER ACOSTA WITH THAT WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S A COMMITTEE ON ANTHONY
TAMA HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
WERE EXCITED ABOUT THIS MEASURE
AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
OUR COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS
WHICH ARE INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
HAVE A LONG TRACK RECORD OF
PROVIDING FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES.
AND THIS IS JUST A NATURAL
PROGRESSION OF THAT.
ANECDOTALLY I'VE SPOKEN WITH
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS MEASURE.
BECAUSE IN MORE RUGGED OR RURAL
AREAS.
THEIR CONSTITUENTS ARE BEING
LEFT BEHIND
AND THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
SUPPORT NEW ROUTES
TO OUR CLOSING THAT GAP AND THAT
DID DON'T EVERYTHING THESE FINE
GENTLEMAN SAID. THANK YOU.
IF THINK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMITTEE A
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WHICH I THE CLOSENESS SHALL I
ABSOLUTELY I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ARE ON THE
PREVIOUS SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A FIRST.
WE HAVE A SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ROLE IN THIS MEASURE DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS.
MOTIONS TO PASS SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE. BONTA.
CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
KAMLAGER-DOVE. KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE
LOW.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUOTES OVER.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO.
SIX THE THREE MEASURES ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF THEM
FOR ADDITIONAL.
FIVE MINUTES
THE PROBLEM MAY BE.
LIFTING THE CALL ON A V.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE.
MOTION IS DEPOSITS. EDUARDO
GARCIA.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I.
SEVEN THREE MEASURES OUT WE'RE
STILL EVEN THE ROLL OPEN FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THREE MINUTES
ADAMS.
AB NINETEEN NINETY NINE MOTIONS
DEPARTS BONTA BONTA AYE.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
A THREE EASURES OUT ROLE STILL
OPEN
WE'RE LEAVING THE ROLE OPEN FOR
AN ADDITIONAL COUPLE MINUTES FOR
JUST ONE MORE MEMBER WAS LEFT
THINK
WELL IF THE CALL ON A FOR ADD
ONS TO A. B. NINETEEN NINETY
NINE.
NINE TO THREE OF THE MEASURE
CARRIES AND WE ARE NOW TURNING
TO ME.
THAT'S. NOT